- Hello teachers,
I'm Sal Khan, founder of the
not-for-profit Khan Academy,
and I'm here to announce a nationwide
back to school learning
challenge called LearnStorm.
LearnStorm is an exciting
way to jump start
your school year around
learning activities.
It's designed to motivate your students
and to help build their growth mindset.
- This year was amazing with LearnStorm,
I had a group of students
that couldn't add,
subtract, multiply, or divide fractions.
They avoided it at all costs,
but since it was an assignment,
they would try it and they
would eventually do much better.
And what was amazing was that
the lower achieving students
were able to see that they
were part of something huge.
They were able to contribute,
(cheering)
and that, I thought, boosted
their self-confidence,
their self-esteem, and I didn't realize
that would happen after
doing a LearnStorm.
(cheering)
(clapping)
(warm bouncy music)
- LearnStorm is a good
way to differentiate
and as well as motivate.
And with the growth mindset pieces,
you can also educate them about
why it's important to learn,
how they learn, how their
body is set up to learn,
what strategies help them learn.
It's amazing, it's amazing and it's free!
(laughing)
It's free!
- We think this is really
going to motivate your students
to understand, to
appreciate that they truly
can learn learn anything.
The activities have been designed
to have measurable gains
in learning attitudes.
- One thing I learned from
the growth mindset activities
is that your intelligence can grow
just like your muscles can grow
and that's something that
really stuck with me.
'Cause I didn't know that before.
- I did over 300 lessons in one week.
I felt proud of myself, getting
all of these good grades.
- It helps the students tremendously,
their confidence is higher,
they're able to do it
and it warms my heart
that they think that way now.
And they know that they can keep going
and keep growing and nothing
will stand in their way.
- So together, as we jump
start the school year,
I look forward for all of us
living the LearnStorm motto,
to keep going and to keep growing.
(all chanting "Go and cheat!")